das war nicht die woche von christine
lambrecht die verteidigungsministerin
hat richtig ärger wegen dieses fotos
unbedacht gepostet bei instagram von
ihrem sohn den sie im helikopter der
luftwaffe mitgenommen hat und alle
fragten sich sofort wie sohnemann fliegt
mit auf staatskosten oder was ich bin
als ministerin in der situation dass ich
sehr wenig zeit habe für privatleben und
insbesondere für den kontakt mit meinem
sohn wenn sie bei allem so eifrig in
ihren dienst geschäften wäre wie bei der
mitnahme ihres sohnes dann stünde es um
die verteidigung und um die bundeswehr
besser in diesem land ok friedrich merz
billige attacke wir grüßen die heli
affäre für euch auf versprochen aber die
verteidigungsministerin die hat auch
sonst ein image problem denn was jetzt
immer klarer wird all das was christine
lambrecht versprochen hat an schweren
waffen für die ukraine also panzer also
haubitzen also ringtausch das kommt bis
jetzt dort gar nicht an eine
verteidigungsministerin die sich
andauernd selbst verteidigen muss was
wird das reicht das für rücktritt der
jetzt von vielen seiten gefordert wird
also lasst uns die performance der
ministerin may genauer angucken und zwar
das fachliche und die b note und ihr
könnten wir natürlich auch gerne sagen
was denkt ihr soll sie muss sie erlöst
werden von ihrem amt schreibt sie mir
gerne in die kommentare ich freue mich
echt das zu lesen aber jetzt erstmal
augen geradeaus
[Applaus]
dabei hat alles mal so schön angefangen
sie wird eine ganz ganz bedeutende
verteidigungsministerin der
bundesrepublik deutschland sagen
christine lambrecht also die vorher
schon justizministerin und ganz kurz
zugleich auch mal familienministerin war
und da eigentlich immer ein ganz
passablen job gemacht hat fanden alle
die dann eigentlich schon ihren abschied
von der politik verkündet hatte
christine lambrecht wollte nämlich
eigentlich längst in politrend seien
wieder als anwältin arbeiten aber dann
dann hat die spd überraschend die wahl
gewonnen und plötzlich wollte frau
lambrecht doch wieder dabei sein wollte
eigentlich gerne innenministerin werden
aber das ging dann nicht weil anna ja
das hat ganz viel mit quoten zu tun und
mit parteienproporz in seinem kabinett
lange geschichte gesucht wurde
jedenfalls noch am ende eine
verteidigungsministerin ja und das hat
sie sich natürlich auch zugetraut
konnte ja keiner wissen dass aus der
verteidigungsministerin innerhalb
weniger wochen eine echte kriegs
ministerin werden muss lambrecht hatte
vorher noch nie zu tun mit dem thema
verteidigung die hatte schlicht keine
ahnung okay das hatte ursula von der
leyen damals auch nicht als die
verteidigungsministerin wurde aber die
hat sich so erzählt man dass sich
zumindest im ministerium reingekniet die
hat die ersten sechs wochen lang nur
akten gefressen und militärs aus gefragt
ganz anders christine lambrecht die soll
an der unterrichtung über
auslandseinsätze
beschaffungswesen nato verpflichtungen
usw jetzt nicht so sehr interessiert
gewesen sein und das beste sie ist kurz
nach ihrem amtsantritt erst mal in
urlaub gefahren da war man schon sehr
erstaunt im ministerium aber niemand mag
das laut sagen gleich gar nicht vor
einer kamera
[Musik]
dieses foto hier habt ihr vielleicht
schon mal gesehen erst dort truppen
besucht der neuen ministerin in litauen
und christine lambrecht lässt sich von
zwei soldaten aus dem panzerfahrzeug
helfen ja es sieht aus als hätte sie
spaß aber ich sage mal es ist nicht so
wirklich gute pr für eine neue
führungskraft nächstes fettnäpfchen
lambrecht ist zu besuch im afrikanischen
mali ich bin da auch schon gewesen auch
begleit reisen mit früheren
verteidigungsminister rinnen und ich
weiß dass meine feuer vom ministerium
eine sehr detaillierte packliste bekommt
da steht dann also zum beispiel wüsten
stiefel mitbringen mindestens jedenfalls
festes schuhwerk aber das hat sie
wahrscheinlich auch nicht lambrecht
kommt also in ihren geliebten high heels
in die wüste und handelt sich dafür
natürlich gleich den ersten schätzung
ein soldaten sauer auf stöcke
schulministerin titelt die bild hätte
man wissen können lambrecht fremdelt mit
der truppe und das merkt man einfach
wenn sie zum beispiel bei instagram
schreibt sie habe sich heute mit der
bundesmarine getroffen dabei heißt die
schon ganz lange deutsche marine sowas
kommt natürlich gar nicht gut an in der
bundeswehr dort klagen sie das ist jetzt
schon die dritte fachfremde ministerin
die wir an lernen müssen aber es ist
insgesamt nicht ideal und das finden
natürlich auch viele soldatinnen
soldaten in der bundeswehr so wenn immer
wieder ihre oberste führung sich von
null an einarbeiten muss in diese
komplexe materie der
verteidigungspolitik das fällt natürlich
leichter wenn da ein bisschen mehr
kontinuität drin wäre in der expertise
an der spitze
[Musik]
natürlich darf christine lambrecht
urlaub machen auch wenn krieg ist das
mal vorweg und ja sie darf auch ihren
sohn im dienst helikopter mitnehmen das
hat sie schon als justizministerin
mehrfach gemacht und das lassen die
richtlinien einfach zu sie hat es vorher
angemeldet und inzwischen auch bezahlt
261 euro um genau zu sein das entspricht
dem lufthansa economy tarif für diese
strecke und übrigens so was machen
andere auch hier der frühere
entwicklungsminister gerd müller zum
beispiel der hat immer wieder seine frau
mit auf reisen um die welt genommen hat
er dann immer betont ich bezahle ja auch
dafür aber gerade im krieg muss eine
verteidigungsministerin daneben auch
damit leben dass alle ganz genau
hingucken eben weil sie
verteidigungsministerin ist eben weil
krieg ist ja und da stellen sich bei
dieser helikopter geschichte einfach
noch andere fragen erstens hat sie sich
diesen termin extra dahin gelegt weil es
von dort nur noch ein sprung in den
osterurlaub nach sylt war lambrecht hat
das bataillon elektronische kampfführung
in norddeutschland besucht dort gibt gar
keine kaserne sondern muss ein
antennenfeld wo elektronische signale
abgefangen werden es gab keine presse
begleitung keine statements alles was
uns so üblich ist und ein schelm wer
böses dabei denkt der autozug nach sylt
ist von da nur 21 kilometer entfernt
aber wie gesagt es war legal im
verteidigungsausschuss rollen sie hinter
den kulissen natürlich mit den augen von
instinktlos bis dämlich haben wieder
alles gehört vor der kamera will
natürlich keiner so richtig die
ministerin beschädigen aber wer genau
hinhört der hört es raus es ist
juristisch offensichtlich möglich wenn
keine juristin nicht alles was
juristisch möglich ist ist unbedingt
politisch sinnstiftend so schön es ist
wenn kinder ein auch im dienst begleiten
können wenn hier für derartige
ressourcen genutzt werden die er viel
geld für den steuerzahler kosten dann
muss das aufgeklärt werden das ist jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen quatsch weil der
heli wäre so oder so geflogen und das
weiß die union auch also nichts wofür
man zurücktreten müsste aber schon eine
geschichte mit geschmäckle aber es gibt
eine zweite frage die ich auch nicht
ohne finde hat christine lambrecht
versucht die veröffentlichung der
geschichte zu verhindern es war nämlich
so dass die zeitung die welt vor dem
erscheinen der story fragen an ihn
ministerin gestellt hat das ist so
üblich mann gibt ihr die gelegenheit
sich zu den vorwürfen zu äußern und dann
gab es vom ministerium vorab den
inoffiziellen hinweis die volljuristin
lambrecht behalte sich rechtliche
schritte gegen eine mögliche
berichterstattung vor zitat ende hallo
die ehemalige justizministerin drohte
mal vorsorglich mit dem anwalt falls es
unliebsame berichterstattung gibt der
welt journalist hat sich davon gar nicht
beeindrucken lassen und hat die
begleitumstände gleich nochmal mit
veröffentlicht und lambrecht hatten im
zdf dazu gesagt dass er alles ganz
normal also ich behalte mir bei allen
äußerungen die über mich oder meine
familie getroffen werden vor
entsprechend dann auch darauf zu
reagieren wenn es zu falschen
tatsachenbehauptungen konnte aber es
gibt noch eine dritte frage wer hat
dieses foto vom sohn eigentlich gemacht
und gibt dabei die sicht frei auf die
sensible cockpit technologie eines
regierungs helikopters darauf gibt es
vom ministerium übrigens bis jetzt keine
antwort also was meint ihr legal und
völlig okay oder einfach nur instinktlos
als ministerin schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
[Musik]
und da sind wir nun also mitten im krieg
in europa mit der schwächsten ministerin
im kabinett die jetzt plötzlich auch
noch ein riesen haufen geld zusätzlich
verwalten muss nämlich die 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr ausgerechnet diese christine
lambrecht soll nun federführend
entscheiden wie das viele geld
ausgegeben wird eine fachfremde muss die
bundeswehr umrüsten kann sie das da darf
man ein bisschen zweifeln was die
ukraine unterstützung angeht gelingt ihr
jedenfalls bis jetzt kaum was für die
5000 helme
die sie der ukraine als erstes großzügig
verspricht wird lambrecht im in und
ausland verlacht das ist ein witz
was muss ein witz sein später sagt sie
die bundeswehr habe gar keine schweren
waffen übrig dann findet sie doch noch
welche dann verspricht die sieben
haubitzen dann irgendwas zwischen 50 und
100 meter für die gibt's aber gar keine
munition
dann soll es einen ringtausch mit
panzern geben jetzt ist zu hören da
bewegt sich gar nichts weil nämlich die
slowenen sagen warum sollen wir denn
halbwegs intakte kampfpanzer für euren
schützenpanzer hergeben eigentlich
logisch dass da dem ukrainischen
botschafter mal wieder der kragen platzt
seit drei wochen lieben anliegen anträge
für
188 leopard-panzer einst die alten im
kanzleramt und werden nicht gebilligt
und ich habe da auch zweifel ob das
geschieht es ist ein kommunikatives
desaster und es ist ein management
desaster verantwortet natürlich auch von
der verteidigungsministerin olaf scholz
zu hört man setzt inzwischen nur noch
auf den generalinspekteur der bundeswehr
der soll die lieferung koordinieren das
sagt auch viel aus über das standing der
ministerin was ist da los warum gibt es
bis heute für diese zugesagten waffen
keine exportgenehmigung und die union
treibt lamprecht regelrecht vor sich her
die ministerin muss jetzt mal beweisen
dass sie dieses amt so ernst nimmt dass
die bundeswehr auch vertrauen kann hier
ist nachhol arbeit zu leisten
tja und hier schließt sich der kreis
olaf scholz und seine schwärmerei für
christine lambrecht wisst ihr noch sie
wird eine ganz ganz bedeutende
verteidigungsministerin der
bundesrepublik deutschland
vielleicht wird sie auch eine ganz ganz
enttäuschende verteidigungsministerin
der bundesrepublik deutschland sein
trotzdem stolz kann lambrecht kaum
entlassen da müsste sie sich schon einen
richtigen schnitzer leisten denn er hat
gar keine andere die eine andere frau
die sich fachlich hervorragend eignen
würde marie agnes strack zimmermann von
der fdp vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses
die darf nicht weil sie nämlich in der
falschen partei ist und so lässt scholz
seine sprecherin diese woche schon zum
zweiten mal ausrichten dass der
bundeskanzler mit der
verteidigungsministerin eng und
vertrauensvoll zusammenarbeite ja genau
und immer wenn man das so betonen muss
dann weiß die politische beobachter in
genau es läuft gar nicht gut so und
jetzt ihr wie fällt ihr urteil über die
ministerin aus schreibt uns gerne in die
kommentare
zeigt uns abonniert uns und gut bitte
all diese tollen videos meiner
kolleginnen und kollegen aus dem zdf
hauptstadtstudio und jetzt wo rühren und
wegtreten sagt man da so urlaub